I saw you guys shortly afterwards I saw
you at uh the premiere of nope
yeah yeah yeah you know dude when I saw
you then we were watching
um I just I I mean how proud of you I
mean I I looked at Jordan I was like I
can't [__] believe it it's amazing I
believe it right but it's just like
there's a pro that was a great movie
that was a good night man yes he is I
mean I remember he was a man I don't I
don't think I'm talking out of school
that he was a little frustrated when we
were mad no wonder because he did our
podcast he talked about it you talked
about it yeah yeah he was definitely
frustrated and done being there and then
like since he left there like he does
like one of the best sketch comedy shows
of all time he is in my opinion like top
five sketch actors of all time like
without he does not get enough [__]
credit yeah he is like next level but
when Keegan and him would like they
during table Wars they would put the
tables to the side and they would
perform yeah sketches live yeah it was
why and then you were in your head
you're like oh this is gonna get picked
up yeah they're crushing yeah and then
he stops that and then becomes like one
of the seminal filmmakers of Our
Generation it's really amazing he's the
best you know he I I've never talked
about this before I want to talk about
what he told me after the note at the
note Premiere at the did you did he tell
you about this about
because remember the scene where the
monkey is on the set of the sitcom
sitcom and he's killing everybody yeah
well you know where he shot that right
where we shot Mad TV no way yeah and he
goes
um I'm the monkey
and I go okay and he goes okay and
you're the little boy underneath the
table I had to kill you it's you're
hiding No No I gave you a pound remember
right
so who am I one of the Gaffers give me
my [__] face torn off
thanks Jordan yeah but when he told me
that I was like wow man you know like he
put that in because he had so much anger
yeah mad right and he put it in a scene
I didn't even I'm so stupid I'm like
this is scary seed
I don't find meaning
that scene was pretty pretty brutal the
scene where they [__] get sucked up
into the thing I was like I was
Nightmare zone for me yeah you know I
met at the after party Corey Feldman
that's right he was in a row yeah I oh I
I came here the last time I asked
someone to take a picture Corey Feldman
I was like [__] man that's a big one oh
he was so nice so small I know he's like
a little child and they busted a couple
Michael Jackson moves
that's right I do remember I remember
sitting it next to me was Riz Ahmed yeah
and I could not focus the whole time
because like the night of is like one of
my favorite shows oh yeah he was good on
that [__] but how does Corey filming
make money
residuals from Lost Boys cameos oh Cameo
yeah yeah I don't know you never did
Cameo did you uh I've never gone on it
but I've ordered many cameos
I won't go on the app and have they
asked you yeah they actually texted me
yeah they texted me and I was like I
don't like that but I like who have you
ordered from uh uh I got uh I got Mindy
Kaling for her birthday I got her
Anthony's scaramucci remember that guy
oh yeah yeah he was like uh hey Mindy
it's me
Davis for being in the white house for
18 days anyways here's my kids he turned
the camera over and it was like his kids
like
who is the governor of Illinois
baseball fan in here he was a manager
for the White Sox he's really funny he's
like uh he's just he's sends you a nice
nice message when he's on like his 50th
beer
Oh Ellen man your family loves you man
I love you so much wait who did you get
what oh doctor now from my 600 pound
life yeah oh yeah yeah
um I want to talk about the three year
and a half years oh suck in the dark but
then what happened well that three years
I was just not getting anything yeah
yeah the only movies the only work I was
getting were like I did those some of
those spoof movies oh that's